what did s alaih wasallam do in order to
welcome Ramadan what was his preparation
for Ramadan there a Hadith which is
mentioned in s bukari r number three
book of fasting Hadith number 1969 the
wife of the Prophet AA may Allah be
pleased with her she says that the
prophet he never fasted any month
completely except the month of Ramadan
and in no month did he fast as many days
as he fasted in the month of shaan so
from this Hadith we come to know that
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
in order to welcome the month of Ramadan
he used to start he used to prepare
himself and fast more in the previous
month that is the month of shaan that
was his way how he used to prepare for
the month of Ramadan and further if you
read say
in chapter number 50 Hadith number 3451
which says that t may Allah be pleased
with him he said on the authority of his
father that his father that is his
grandfather he said whenever the prophet
saw the new moon used to always pray to
Allah subhana wa tala and say oh Allah
bless us in this month and used to
mention the name of that month and then
say that please keep us steadfast in
faith in this month this was the way the
prophet always used to pray to Allah
subhana wa taala whenever he saw a new
moon it wasn't specifically only for the
the new moon of the month of Ramadan but
it was for all new moons whenever used
to see and his special way of welcoming
the month of Ramadan was that he used to
mention about the coming of this blessed
month to the
people and it's mentioned in mus Ahmed R
number two page number 230 Hadith number
7148 where Prophet m sallallah al
wasallam used to tell the people that oh
people this blessed month is approaching
you and Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the Devils will be
Chained and in this month there is a
night which is better than a thousand
months and if anyone is deprived of
Allah subhana wa tala's blessing in this
month he's truly a deprived person so
here we come to know that this is how
Prophet malli wasallam used to welcome
this month and he used to tell the good
news of the Blessed month to come to all
the people